Another common question that we get is about the different types of search campaign
So people ask is a search campaign better than a call-only campaign
So in the training we set up two different ones
We set up the call-only campaign and we also have a video for the website search traffic with the call-out extension
I feel for the majority of the Legion stuff that we're doing that the website
The search traffic with the call-out extension is going to be the most versatile for you
It's going to give you the most utility for the majority of the legions that we're running having said that though the call campaign works
for things that are
emergency urgent 24 hours
They do have a place where if you're running a like a web search campaign
Oversay like a city area and you want to kind of spread out into a rural area that doesn't have a big population
Sometimes there's not a lot of call search
Competition out there and you can run that ad in those rural areas and it's really cheap and easy to do and it can just
Maybe get you a handful more leads per month, but you don't need to run both
You run them separate if you're going to do it, but I would recommend the website search traffic with the call-out extension